welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University
visit
my name is Larry the Patrick welcome to
I think in Belem University
I thought with her name boy it was up in
the hallway that you know where they are
teaching of course at urban farming and
the environment
tonight we are exploring the second of
two public lectures and the second of
four public lectures dealing with local
economy and urban farming some of you
may have been president about a month
ago for James quilling it when James
came our inaugural lecture on that topic
so we're continuing tonight with the
president's applies to children I want
to recognize just a few people in in the
in the room before we get started I want
to recognize in here in the year our
undergraduate Provost because none of
this would happen without Indira's total
support for all courses green on campus
and from my perspective the urban
farming course we never have flour
without professor years
I want to acknowledge her presence and
dedication to the co-sponsors for the or
the co-organized apply should say for
the public lecture series is Fernando
Barbosa will be interviewing a
introducing Michael Marybeth sty slinger
Rene and Michael Petrovic
I'd like to list or announce the
supporters for the public lecture series
if I may and they are follows attorney
Valentine school policy and public
policy and management East End food
co-op I saw Rob here only to go
faith in economic development council
and green black cards anybody here from
green black farm okay I think you woke
up double boys groan Pittsburgh I know
Miriam is here she told me that the
entire Grove Pittsburgh staff is here so
it's for Penn State Extension
Deno anybody from Penn State they are
also supporters of this public lecture
series degree bow through urban
ecological collaborative begin to very
buff spice Nagar and to the urban farm
in addition as Carol Walsh Journal hi
Carol okay so those are the supporters
to the public lecture series now here's
the big question I'd like to recognize
all ribbon farmers just by name
Mildred's daughter Ronda barber not here
he'll crest farmer Maria are you here
Hillcrest our branding farm I know Jeff
is here Garden of Dreams Mindy Schwartz
I know you are here
landslides are is anyone here from our
urban farm lands life our mum dynasty
Chris I know you're here
mid wealth center anybody okay thank you
for your presence green black harem I've
already asked about blackberry farms
some peri-urban farms anybody here from
blackberry farm peri-urban and I even
understand there's somebody here in Cool
Springs organics in one their colony so
we've pulled in a few farmers who are
little bit beyond beyond the city how
many students are here from the urban
farming class show me is there better be
twenty two hands
alright alright we're going to get to
the introduction of my experiment he did
make make the request that I highlighted
on the back on the back table are some
folks and publications of various things
dealing with small revolution so please
check them up on your way out and also
speaking to the bathroom there will be
some light refreshments afterwards so to
hang around you know especially you
urban farming students get over and
actually meet the heroines the uncommon
pyramids Pittsburgh the urban farmers
who are growing food ok so here we go I
was putting this course together early
summer I kept getting CC emails from
Fernando and Mary Beth about local
economy I I couldn't understand why I
was being CC but it was happening at
about that time I was putting to this
course together in my head trying to
figure out Howard with farming should be
taught this time around and what came to
me was urban farming within the context
of local economy so I got Mary Beth and
Fernando Tsun Tsun Michael and as soon
as Rene got back from Oxford we got
together and planned this series of
public lectures around the theme of
local economy
so James Cole Ian guess it gave us the
idea that there were simultaneity is one
of which was the simultaneous solution
of some of our problems being found both
at the Commons level the public comments
level at the international scale and
also at the local scale so that's what
we're going to
tonight one of those tales tonight's
theme is local economy so I will turn
things over to Fernando who will
introduce Michael Shuman Thank You Larry
everybody who gets in the program okay
so look at fantastic good evening
everybody and I'm really thrilled to be
here when Larry first we're about to do
I'm trying to put together this lecture
series together
I kind of wonder to myself boy you know
I'm no you ever around here I did I'm
not proof detergent maybe starting about
try this is something that deals with
local economies and I got a little we
give you d be something to plant on the
ground now kill it I just don't have
that kind of the top so when the theme
of the lecture became local economies
and urban farming I just had put
together or definitely what it is that I
could contribute but both Mary Beth and
Larry help you see the light in one of
the things that they don't understand is
that through the close promises that he
was describing I've been a Rubio Valley
the Business Alliance for local living
economies for a number of years
essentially really loved the concept of
what they've been doing all over the
country and always wondering what it is
that no someday how is it that they
would find the opportunity to actually
have that type of conversation here in
the Pittsburgh area so as Mary Beth and
Larry began to explain what such be
happening within the farming and
agriculture area
rina sector here in Pittsburgh and also
their particular interest and and I
gotta tell you kudos to CMU
so seeing what's beyond the horizon when
it comes together when it comes to local
economies it just became sort of an
inescapable opportunity I have been on
the valley annual conference in 2006 and
had the opportunity to meet a couple of
the the founders of the organization and
Michael Shipman is one of the
co-founders so was very impressed with
what I saw or heard say but I heard
other people say about him and also Judy
quicks which is the the other the other
founder and by the way a little secret
duty which is originally from Pittsburgh
and she is going to be the speaker in
the April serious lecture
so please do to mark your calendar for
April 29th same time tonight it's going
to be a homecoming for her
it doesn't matter that I'm not
originally from Pittsburgh I think that
there's an issue at the term local is
local this whatever the heart is and we
eat my wife and my two sons moving gears
in 1985 then we just evolved into
regions it's absolutely the trailer for
anything and there is a sentiment for
frankly that I also get from lots of
immigrants that I know from different
parts of the world not just from South
America I'm originally from Peru this
burg is a place that you just can't help
but talk and so when you marry the
concepts of local living economies with
the concept of Agriculture especially
urban farming which is such a powerful
powerful concepts for urban regions that
are trying to be defined themselves in
Pittsburgh does seem to have an
interesting opportunity in that regard
it just became as I said earlier is
capable to try to help with this
particular enterprise so here I am
tonight and again kudos to CMU and
the country of groceries
organizers suggest with very little hint
includes that sedative just kind of kind
of what you have to can help us when I
will shoot up over his bio Tigers two
and a half pages of stuff so I said I'm
going to read all this stuff but I ended
up so summarizing some of those things
that I think I think you just need to
hear
but Michael pass in his near term
history him here and I brought the same
age so I know that you guys have lived
that long but long enough to have a
couple of things those are things to
share with us he's an attorney an
economist and currently the vice
president of enter Chronicle for
enterprise development the training and
development corporation which is
actually based in the state of Maine he
is the former director of the Institute
of policy studies in Washington DC
co-founder of the Business Alliance
local
economy's for Valley these are the
recipients of a scalable national
leadership fellowship is the open of the
seven books including smart evolution
which is the instance of which I'm going
to hear tonight the other book that it
is one that probably should be on many
new years reference bookshelves is going
local creating self-reliant communities
in the global age he has written
articles for many publications including
the nation the Weekly Standard the New
York Times and The Washington Post he's
a frequent commentator in National
Public Radio's all things considered he
has he can sub rather extensive and
provocative instigations
in all aspects of public service social
justice economic equity particularly
exploring people
privacy's and policies in diverse fields
such as technology national security
citizen diplomacy municipal and foreign
policy entrepreneurship philanthropy and
business family and again given our
times contraint constraints here tonight
definitely will not be able to do to
adjust it to something the phenomenal
things that they have been able to to
accomplish in this area but I do the
courage to look him up on the Internet
is well-placed to Google and I don't
want to encourage you to be
people inspired by some of those things
I've been able to put out there he's a
graduate of Stanford University will
forgiving that in stop her law school
and lucky person who lives in Washington
DC with his wife two children
no way not only have I totally
understood why it is that their daddy
never took them to mcdonnell's he's
healthy welcome Michael sure
well thank you for that very kind
introduction and Larry thank you for the
invitation thank you to the sponsors and
all of you folks for coming tonight I
know there are many competing things
nibbling away at all of our attentions
here there's one piece that Fernando did
not reveal about my resume he may not
know this but really my start in the
local food movement came in my my first
job when I was an undergraduate at
Stanford desperate for money
I actually took a job for two weeks with
the IT and t corporation promoting
Twinkies at the local supermarket and I
had to dress in yellow tights and a big
plywood Twinkie the kid costume and go
up to people and say do you know the
Twinkies are now individually wrapped
for freshness
so I've come a long way you could say to
get to local food and maybe that story
will inspire other recalcitrants whether
they're sitting in your audience or
sitting in your living room from time to
time I titled tonight's talk saving the
world by eating local and what I wanted
to do is do a kind of a blend between
big themes that I cover in the small
Mart Revolution and a lot of the themes
around local food that I see happening
around the country the starting place in
my worldview is that we are in a huge
wrestling bout between two archetypes of
capitalism and I give them women's names
tina and louis tina comes from Maggie
Thatcher's invocation there is no
alternative to the global economy TI and
a and I think it's fair to say that over
the last generation economic developers
and politicians and really irrespective
of party and political leanings have
embraced Heena and it really has come
down to three essential mantras the
first is get Toyota to locate in your
backyard
you know some an attraction and
retention paradigm whenever you hear the
words attraction and retention since its
focused on non-local business you should
immediately think ah this is part of
Tina the second part of Tina is
prioritizing export-led development the
belief that this is where real wealth
comes from and the third part of Tina is
convincing local businesses like many
sitting in the room here local farmers
that even though this policy doesn't
directly touch you it actually is all in
your interest so you know sit back
buckle up and enjoy the ride there is an
alternative and that alternative is
Louis for locally owned and import
substituting development this is not a
Louis here this is Jane Jacobs great
urban economist recently deceased and I
think those of you who are familiar with
her work will hear many of the themes
from her books echoing and what I want
to share with you this evening local
ownership is I think we all know it when
we see it it means 51% ownership and
control within a given locale import
substitution is saying really if you can
produce a good and a service locally it
makes sense to do so rather than import
it for a bunch of reasons some of which
will go into some of which we can talk
about in Q&A so really we're talking
about creating self-reliance
the economy toward diversification now
out of this movement of Louis has come
what Fernando already identified the
Business Alliance for local living
economies or Bali founded in the year
2001 it has since grown to I think we're
now at sixty cities around the United
States there are 15,000 businesses that
are formerly members local businesses
but in fact if you look at what the
local business population is in those
sixty communities we're talking about
hundreds of thousands of businesses not
millions and the idea is that these
businesses and these Bali networks are
embracing our that the strongest economy
for reasons we will discuss is one that
maximizes local ownership second idea is
that the strongest economy is going to
be one that simultaneously is as
self-reliant as possible and is engaged
in the global economy and if you think
about it you know sell everything you
can to local consumers and sell
everything you can to the world that is
the definition of the successful economy
and if you take either of those pieces
of way the economy loses something I
think one of the mistakes of mainstream
economic development has been if you the
belief that if you focus on the non
local markets the local markets will
take care of themselves when in fact I
think there is a growing body of
evidence that the causality actually
goes in the other direction that a
strong local market actually will give
birth naturally to businesses to project
themselves globally the last piece of
Bali is that were not interested in any
old businesses were interested in local
businesses that aspire to higher labor
and environmental standards I am sure
there are people sitting
this audience tonight who are nervous if
not antagonistic toward companies that
begin with names like wall or home or
star I'm among them but that is not what
this talk or these ideas or this
movement is all about this is not an
oppositional movement this is a movement
for building stronger more competitive
networks of local businesses and
rendering the other points moot over the
next 50 55 minutes or so I want to share
four big ideas with you one is I want to
give you four good reasons why we should
be embracing local why are you embracing
Lois rather than Tina I want to talk
about why Lois is a lot more competitive
than we think and share some data with
you on that I want to talk about some of
the emerging business strategies that
food businesses in particular are using
to take advantage of this trend and
competitiveness of Lois and then I want
to talk about some emerging community
strategies this obviously should be a
four I'm editing myself here some of you
may remember about it I guess it was
last March April that Time magazine had
this cover story
forget organic eat local was a terrible
article but it was great that this
reached the cover of Time magazine
I mean clearly the zeitgeist moment has
arrived why has it arrived well I think
there is a growing body of evidence that
not all businesses contribute equally to
the well-being of a community now what I
want to do is I want to share with you a
bunch of data and studies that show the
superior performance of local businesses
when it comes to community well-being
over non-local
businesses I'm not saying that the non
local businesses are bad or immoral just
that objectively speaking they don't
contribute as much to income wealth and
jobs this is a this is a study that was
done shortly before I debated the head
of economic development for Lane County
Oregon in 2003 and I was very fortunate
that the local paper looked at about
five years of this guy's tax abatements
that he had awarded in the many millions
of dollars to a bunch of companies in
support of economic development and what
this newspaper article found was that
95% of the subsidies went to six non
local tina businesses three came took
the benefits and within a year or two
shut down the factories and moved
elsewhere to another gullable
jurisdiction on the planet two came
stuck around but under-delivered the
jobs they promised one was more or less
on target the other 5% of the subsidies
went to about a hundred local businesses
they made very modest job promises and
pretty much kept the promises that they
made the bottom line was stunning
because in tax abatement terms the cost
of the lowest job was two thousand
dollars the cost of all of the jobs that
tina produced over this period was about
twenty two thousand dollars but remember
some of those jobs came and went
so in net job terms it was sixty seven
thousand dollars per job to get a job
from tina it was more than thirty times
more expensive to do a tina job strategy
than a lowest job strategy now what was
that just an accident and bad luck for
central oregon well maybe but I actually
think that there are some real things
that are going on with
businesses that almost always will
generate superior economic performance
the first is local businesses don't move
they stick around for many years often
for many generations this is kind of my
exhibit a this is a cheesehead many of
you recognize a cheesehead is a rabid
fan of the Green Bay Packers and the
Packers are important because they are
the only team in the National Football
League not owned by a single obnoxious
individual so while many teams come and
go with their cities threatening to
leave like Art Modell did with Cleveland
if you don't build an estate him and
give him a couple of tens of millions of
dollars of bribery off they go there
will never be Baltimore Packers the
Packers are there to stay the Packers
have generated hundreds of millions of
dollars of wealth for Green Bay and will
continue to do so why because they are
locally owned thousands of residents in
Wisconsin have shares of the Green Bay
Packers and that is why the Packers will
never leave Green Bay so it helps to
underscore why it is local ownership
produces a steady stream of wealth
that's less reliable when it comes to
Tina the flip side of that is that many
Tina companies when they see a global
opportunity lower wages looser
environmental standards closer to
natural resources whatever they move
abroad well this can inflict catastrophe
on a community I first got involved with
the training and Development Corporation
in 2002 because a paper mill in the
middle of Maine had just shut down this
was a big paper
in a town called Millinocket and it
through the last 1400 people out of work
there it was not a locally owned mill I
was owned by a company in Canada and the
Canadians decided they wanted to create
another mill somewhere else lower labor
costs this was a huge catastrophe for
mid make over the next year the
unemployment level in mid Maine was 40
percent it was as if a nuclear bomb went
off in that economy now I know you you
know that you don't have to look far in
the history of this region to see
similar things that have happened and
what you can say as a kind of summary of
all of this is that if you build your
economic development around big tina
companies that will come and go you're
taking a huge risk a huge gamble the
more that you practice economic
development that is rooted in locally
owned businesses it is an insurance
policy against this kind of catastrophe
tripping you up down the road now
there's another piece of this to local
ownership also means that the company is
likely to be more responsible and here's
what I mean by that suppose
hypothetically the Green Bay Packers had
to pay a living wage the city of Green
Bay said everyone in the city including
the hotdog sellers and the ticket
collectors has to be paid a living wage
of 10 plus dollars per hour
well what the would the Green Bay
Packers suddenly pick up and leave they
wouldn't be happy about this but would
they leave no they can't leave because
they're locally owned they're locally
controlled the more of your economy that
is locally owned and rooted means that
you can raise labor and environmental
state
genders politically with confidence that
those businesses are going to adopt
rather than flee the second factor that
differentiates local businesses they
have higher economic multipliers now for
those of you who are unfamiliar with the
term the economic multiplier is the nuts
and bolts of economic development it
means I spend a dollar at a local
pharmacy people work there they take
that dollar go to a local grocer the
local grocer is buying some produce
produced locally so we have a dollar in
circulation the faster this dollar
circulates and the more times this
dollar circulates in a community without
leakage the more income wealth and jobs
that's economic development 101 and it
just so happens that local businesses do
this a lot better than non local
businesses
this is a study that was done in Austin
Texas
about five six years ago looking at the
impact of $100 spent at a local
bookstore book people and $100 spent at
a borders hundred dollars spent at the
borders led to $13 remaining in the
local economy $100 spent at the local
bookstore led to $45 staying in the
local economy
so roughly speaking every time you spend
a dollar at the local book store you get
three times the economic impact three
times the jobs three times the income
and wealth affects three times the tax
benefits were not talking small potatoes
of difference here why was there a
difference
well the borders did not have a high
level management team on the ground the
local bookstore did the borders did not
advertise in local radio and television
the local bookstore did the borders did
not use local business services like
lawyers and accountants the local
bookstore did
the borders did not have a stream of
local prophets coming into the community
the local bookstore did so you just take
those four line items and you easily can
come up with 10 15 20 percent or more of
the expenditure by a business and you
start to generalize from that and you
realize it would truly be an unusual
comparison between a local and a
non-local business of doing the same
thing where you would get a higher
multiplier from the non-local business
so here's a bunch of other studies that
tell us exactly the same thing
a study in Iowa State about a year and a
half ago if you build an ethanol plant
in Iowa with no local ownerships you get
140 jobs if you increase the ownership
to 73 percent local because of the
multiplier impact you more than double
the number of jobs in the state over 300
here's a study from San Francisco last
May looking at the impact of a 10% shift
in retail expenditure from chain to
local if San Franciscans did that they
would create something like 1,700 new
jobs and 200 million dollars more of
economic output or to put this in more
depressing terms if San Franciscans were
foolish enough to move 10 percent of
their expenditures from local to chain
they would lose those jobs and lose 200
million dollars of economic impact
here's a study that I did in Detroit
last June I asked the question suppose
we were to shift 20 percent of people's
expenditure inside the city of Detroit
to local food food grown by urban
farmers and the like and process by
urban based food businesses in Detroit
and you know what we found is that we
would get you know
an enormous impact something like 500
500 million dollars a half billion
dollars more of output significant more
in earnings and-and-and taxes that come
into Detroit and if five counties if
five County said look we really want to
help Detroit get back on its feet and
we're gonna do it by buying Detroit
grown if 20% of the expenditure shifted
you would get three and a half billion
dollars more into the Detroit economy
and in job terms you know just just the
Detroit shift would lead to five
thousand more jobs in the five County
area we're talking about thirty five
thousand more jobs even in a city the
size of Detroit that would have a
sizable impact on unemployment and those
kinds of numbers certainly would be true
for this region as well now I want to
pause for a second about the message
that I'm giving you on these data we now
have more than a dozen studies over the
last 10 years that all show that
focusing economic development on local
businesses is significantly more useful
for the economy significantly more
affordable than doing non local
businesses and there's a message in
there there's a message that public
policy I think needs to focus on because
there's a temptation to say well we're
gonna do some local some non local but
public policy doesn't allow that kind of
you know that kind of loose use of money
I mean think of it well you know we'll
have some like old gas-guzzling cars and
we'll have some new hybrids so we'll
have a diversity of Pleet out there no
you do the thing that works the best and
we now know that local works the best
and so the burden
proof really is on those who would do
economic development the old way on why
you would spend any money on non-local
business the third the third distinction
about local businesses is that they have
a character and a size that is
consistent with the kind of cutting-edge
theories of economic development so
smart growth the idea of having walkable
communities and doing more with existing
space so you protect green spaces and
farmland well if you think about it you
just can't do a walkable community in a
big box hellhole it spatially doesn't
work nor can you do a big industrial
park and make it a walkable community a
walkable community really requires
attention to the size and the character
of businesses increasingly small
increasingly home-based whole downtown's
what is it that drives tourists into an
economy well this is the Insignia of
Austin Texas business community the keep
Austin weird campaign now you might use
a somewhat different set of insignias
and Pittsburgh or not but if you think
about it you know what is it that draws
tourists you know in Austin it's one of
a kind restaurants nightclubs hotels or
put it another way no one goes to
Houston as a tourist which is a big box
hellhole right you know it just there
may be many reasons to go to Houston but
tourism would not be one of them so if
you're interested in tourism in your
economy you want to nurture the local
and the unique characteristics and this
is the same logic but behind your
favorite son richard florida's creative
economy arguments i mean i believe that
at the end of the day the creative
is mostly about Louis there may be five
degrees of difference between Florida's
view of this and mine but a creative
economy really says how do we keep
people like you in the audience the best
the brightest the most entrepreneurial
you know people who are recent graduates
of great universities how do we keep
them here if you have an economy that is
primarily built on hamburger flippers
people turning nuts and bolts on an
assembly line checkout clerks that's the
antithesis of a creative economy a
creative economy is one where every
single person with the dream of setting
up his or her own local business has the
opportunity to do something and that's
why Louis is a critical piece of the
creative economy now the last point I
want to mention is that Louis firms
uniquely can help us reduce carbon
footprints I put this picture of blam up
here because there was a guy named
McWilliams who wrote a a stunningly poor
op-ed in the New York Times we now know
how the New York Times fact checkers are
given McCain stuff but they wrote a
stunningly bad op-ed that said it turns
out this is sort of his words I'm
paraphrasing it turns out that local
lamb in the United Kingdom has four
times the carbon footprint of New
Zealand lamb and therefore the people in
the UK should abandon local lamb and
import lots of New Zealand lamb what I
don't even think McWilliams knew was
that this study was commissioned by the
New Zealand lamb export industry
what he also didn't realize is and I
confirmed this fight emailing back and
forth with the study's authors they
didn't look at local land at all they
compared Bionic lamb in New Zealand
badly done pesticides fertilizers with
badly done land in the United Kingdom
and it turns out that because the
pesticides and fertilizers in New
Zealand are fed by hydropower which is
clean and the pesticides and fertilizers
are fed by coal power in the UK the
Bionic Lambs and UK fared very badly I
focus on this just because you know
there's a lot of these sort of cutesy
counterfactual counter logic studies
that are floating around and when you
undress them they have huge holes in
them because logically it is apparent to
a third grader that local food that
doesn't have enormous food miles
embedded in it is going to carry a lower
carbon footprint than non local food and
the same is true in most local goods it
would truly be an extraordinary
distinction and one of the things about
globalization you know if a community
figures out if a community in Mongolia
figures out how are we going to produce
this particular good with an
exceptionally low amount of carbon
globalisation means that technology will
spread around the planet instantly and
every community will have access to it
so it is extremely hard to envision any
community having a carbon advantage in
trade self reliance is the carbon
advantage moving the economy toward
localization is where you can achieve
the successfully low carbon footprint
now the arguments that I get against all
of this the pushback is actually not on
the arguments that I've presented to you
I mean there's there are people holdouts
out there who disagree with some of
things like I said but I've been
surprised that very few economists have
challenged me on what I've just shared
with you what they come back with though
is they say ok you're right that if we
have a local good and a non local good
same quality price accessibility yes if
we buy local you'll get the multiplier
effect you'll get the wealth effects
you'll get the Smart Growth creative
economy tourists effects low carbon
footprint but but we live in a world
we're bigger is better bigger box is
cheaper bigger businesses achieve better
economies of scale and so you're talking
about local goods that are more
expensive so I want to take this on and
it reminds me a little bit of one of my
favorite movies growing up I many of you
probably have never seen this it's Bambi
versus Godzilla and the essence of the
movie the way that I think about it here
is that Bambi is kind of the small local
businesses out there the urban farms and
then there's the Godzilla of
globalization and in this film's
depiction it's a 1 minute film that's it
for Bambi the way that this argument
plays out is really four different
variations on a theme one one argument
says well local businesses are rare part
of the economy they're the backwater the
old economy why would you focus on that
another argument says most small
businesses fail why should we put our
eggs in the failing basket most small
businesses can't innovate and they
certainly can't compete globally so
let's take these apart a little bit
the first about local businesses being a
rare part of the economy and point of
fact if you look at the US gross
domestic product about half of the
private sector is small and local six
percent of the economy is nonprofit
cooperatives hospitals universities
chances are very
Carnegie Mellon is not going to move to
China and then there are you know the
governmental institutions local and
state and federal you add that all up
that's 58 percent of GDP 58 percent of
GDP is place-based
the majority of the economy is
place-based the majority of the
competitive economy is place-based
so it's the minority that needs some
explaining and in point of fact there
are many things that economists leave
out because we don't know how to count
them like stay-at-home parents like
people who take care of the elderly like
them you know the volunteer sector like
the black market you start adding all of
these things together and really in a
typical part of the US economy 80% of
the activity that goes on today is local
and it starts to underscore why any
economic development policy that focuses
on the non local 20% is fundamentally
misplaced it's too small a part of the
economy to draw our interest we should
be focusing on the biggest part of the
economy what about the most the argument
that most small businesses fail not true
what we've heard is something else and
we haven't paid attention to it most
small business startups fail most large
business startups fail most of all
startups fail but that doesn't mean that
in any given year most small businesses
are failing in the most recent year that
I had data available for the small mark
book there were 32,000 more small
business births than deaths and 200 more
large business deaths than births those
are numbers that would surprise some
people most small businesses can't
innovate hardly SBA data suggests that
six
80% of all new jobs are coming from
smaller businesses 13 to 14 times more
patents per unit of business are in
small businesses what about the larger
issue of competitiveness I want to I
want to approach this question a little
bit differently that you might have
thought about it every year the US
government catalogues all businesses in
our economy and what is called the North
American industrial classification
system NACE 1,300 categories and it also
says what's the size of these businesses
well if you ask the question in how many
of these 1,300 categories do we have
more examples of successful large
businesses than small businesses the
answer is a whopping seven in other
words in twelve hundred and ninety three
categories we have more examples of
successful small businesses than large
businesses now what are those seven
categories that are really hard to
localize well number one is running a
centralized monetary system ok will
concede that one number two is running a
nuclear power plant we can see why in
Florida today number three number three
is rockets and missiles and surely if
there was a category that would be hard
to envision localization of it would be
one with an intergalactic mission right
and yet in this category we have ten
businesses nationally and four of them
are small and locally owned so that one
turns out to be open to you my point
here is that economists tend to be very
Cavalier on this economy of scale issue
it it almost sounds like you know
someone has gone up to you know Mount
Sinai and pulled the tablets down Moses
the others show not too small
scale manufacturing it doesn't work that
way
the clever entrepreneur and the smart
economic developer looks for great
examples of small scale success in every
single sector of the economy and puts
those into motion because there is truly
almost no sector out there that you
cannot have small scale globally
competitive success if you shop around
carefully and wisely enough now
nevertheless our view of globalization
is a much more pernicious one you know
we see ourselves being steamrolled by
the Walmarts the Home Depot's Starbucks
that pet smarts now everything I just
mentioned to you is retail and here is
something that people do not realize
even though retail seems like a huge
part of our economy it's where we
encounter it retail is 7% of our economy
and it's true that in retail small
businesses have really taken a beating
over the last 10 years old though not as
big as you think in non retail small
businesses have actually done really
well and overall if you look at like
what percentage of the gross domestic
product has gone to small versus large
small businesses have lost only about
three or four percent of ground over the
last decade that's a much smaller number
than we assumed and it's mostly a big
loss in certain retail categories
counterbalance by some small gains and a
bunch of other categories that small
businesses had now you could still look
at that three to four percent loss that
small business has experienced and say
all right
well that is evidence that small
businesses are less competitive maybe
but let's entertain it
some other hypotheses about why small
businesses have had a hard time of it
the first is that every single year
state and local governments including
your own have given fifth an estimated
fifty billion dollars for attraction or
retention now as I said earlier on
attraction and retention is code phrase
for non-local because you it doesn't
make sense to attract or retain a local
business it's a it's a non sequitur the
feds as I look at their pork-barrel
stuff that's going on probably are
giving 63 billion dollars a year to non
local business that's a hundred and
thirteen billion dollars of for each
year and one way to look at this is that
these are subsidies the result of which
if not the purpose is to make local
business less competitive the second
thing to think about equity is bias I
know a lot of people here are young and
you're not thinking about pension funds
yet but by show of hands here how many
people Bank local okay so looks like
about two-thirds okay by show of hands
here those of you who have pension funds
that you're aware of how many of you
have those pension funds investing local
now notice the difference and that
difference is actually quite significant
because banking is only one sixth of the
financial universe of the u.s. the other
five six are stocks bonds mutual funds
hedge funds venture funds and there is
no local content in that whatsoever
the reason turns out to be we have
securities laws that were enacted in the
early Jurassic period that make it
extremely expensive for small businesses
to attract small investors they have to
hire 50 to $100,000 worth of lawyers to
pay for the transaction it's absurd that
we have that requirement but the result
is a bias in the equities market
half of the economy of the private
economy is small local business half the
competitive economy is small local
business and they get almost none of the
equity funds out there from our pensions
or mutual funds that is what economists
might dryly observe is a market failure
it is a Mis allocation of resources that
means all of us in this room who you
know I'd say maybe 90% seem to be local
least as a local voice of one kind or
another all of us in this room are over
investing in fortune 500 companies and
neglecting local businesses that we know
are essential for our well being and
then there are a bunch of other little
things like buy a book from a local book
store or pay a sales tax buy it from
Amazon no sales tax twenty five years
ago if Walmart was doing what it was
doing today with its suppliers they
would be hauled off to the pokey for
antitrust violations today we give them
a free pass we could spend all day going
through all of the biases that are
tilted like a Double Diamond ski slope
against local business so let's let's
put this all in perspective 113 billion
dollars of pork each year that's making
small local business less competitive
equities laws that are wrecking the
ability of small businesses to capture
investment and all of these other public
policies that are biased against local
business no wonder local businesses have
lost three or four percent let's put it
a different way it's a miracle they only
lost three or four percent it shows how
resilient the sector is that despite all
of the efforts of public policy to
destroy these businesses they continue
if we got public policy half right over
the last decade there
never would have been this 3 or 4
percent loss in their market share and
if we get public policy half right in
the next 10 years you will see a small
Mart revolution because there are a lot
of trends out there that are happening
nationally and globally that are making
small more and more competitive here's
one trend it's a golden arch french
fries and the words locally owned this
is a poster that McDonald's commissioned
in the Central Terminal of National
Airport
apparently McDonald's wants you to feel
like when you order your Big Mac your
kinda sort of supporting the local
economy man you know and and you know
this is how they think they're gonna
sell things right and look at these
other examples of local wash HSBC the
world's local bank are okay the nation's
local builder shop local calm without a
single local business inside of it
apparently we're onto something because
as soon as consumers discover like this
isn't the real thing they're gonna move
to what is the real thing consumers are
beginning to move toward local because
they're seeing these numbers they're
seeing the health effects and the
environmental effects of local and
they're seeing the the ability to deal
with the carbon and climate changes in a
more constructive way reason number two
for optimism globalization often leads
to great efficiencies in production but
it is led to great inefficiencies in
distribution and there is no better
place to see this than in food these
numbers were developed by the former
Secretary of Agriculture for the state
of Maine their national data and what
what they do is they show when you spent
a dollar at a market in the year 1900
$0.40 went to the farmer and the rest
went to inputs and marketing today
extend this forward to about two
thousand five six seven cents goes to
the farmer 73 cents goes to marketing by
marketing I mean packaging refrigeration
advertising middle people trucking
things that have nothing to do with food
well if you think about it whenever the
marketing number gets very large
relative to production there is an
opportunity for localization because I
mean think about it take the seven cents
here and suppose we have really
inefficient local farmers so instead of
seven for seven cents it's fourteen
cents well if you've gotten rid of most
of the 73 cents of garbage you still
have low you have cheaper food and so I
think that there is an underlying
economic reason why we're beginning to
see an acceleration of farmers markets
urban farming Community Supported
Agriculture other kinds of Community
Food Systems it's because of the
gigantic inefficiency that local bit
that the global businesses are now
facing and by the way this is going to
get a lot worse so this is my number
reason number three for optimism this is
the price of oil West Texas crude
between 1998 and the present even an
economist would have to concede that the
price of oil is rising
well you know that's bad news for some
people on a limited income but it's
great news for communities it's great
news for local food systems it means
we're gonna be using our non-local cars
and non local fuels a lot less we're
gonna be doing a lot more smart growth
we're going to be doing more local
energy efficiency and local production
coupled with local consumption is going
to become increasingly competitive
against Walmart production in China
that's bringing the goods fifteen
thousand miles to the United States even
by the way if the labor in China is free
which it almost is because those tiny
labor costs are becoming a less and less
significant part of the equation and the
large the getting larger transportation
costs are dominating the equation so
we're gonna see we're gonna see a huge
upheaval in the globalised food system
over the coming generation reason number
four for optimism dead pets you know
Chinese dog food kills you know
thousands of us dogs ecoli from non
local spinach infects thousands of
people in the United States and suddenly
people realize maybe there's an
advantage here for local spinach mad cow
disease coming from Canada we are
starting to see more and more reasons
why consumers want to have a
relationship with a farmer and want to
trust where the food has come from
now the next thing I want to talk about
is I want to talk about how local
businesses are taking advantage of these
trends and local food businesses in
particular I don't know how many of you
know this guy this is Paul Saginaw Paul
Saginaw is the founder of Zingerman's
delicatessen and animal
and you know one of the things that's
great about Zingerman's as a strategy
for building a local business is it's a
great story because Paul and his partner
Ari who have run this delicatessen for
the better part of I think 25 years made
a commitment at the beginning we are
going to grow but we're gonna grow deep
we're not going to grow wide so we're
gonna take the success from our
delicatessen and we're gonna create
related businesses a bakery a Creamery a
wedding cake manufacturer we're gonna
create a big business consulting firm
we're going to create a coffee company
and they're still going out of this one
local delicatessen they now have a
business that generates annual sales of
over thirty million dollars and employs
five hundred and forty five people in
Ann Arbor and they will always be a
local business another strategy that
local businesses I think are beginning
to realize this you need to create a
destination and maybe the way to create
a destination is not on your own but
it's a bunch of local businesses
together kind of a local shopping mall
as you were this comes from one of my
favorite local shopping malls in the
world the bangkok weekend market where
there are 10,000 local businesses side
by side I think you know you have to
walk like ten miles to see all of them
now when I was growing up on the south
shore of Long Island there was a place
called the farmers market it wasn't
really a farmers market it was a big box
and it had about a hundred booths inside
of there some were food but what it
really was was a lot of home-based
businesses and artisans that sort of
occupied those booths as a kid this was
the place I love to go I mean we had
chain stores then Pergamon and Time
scare but this was the place that was
fun where you could watch a glassblower
make elaborate animals and see a
magician for
form tricks all day long we need to
create fun places for local businesses
to be and that becomes part of the
competitive advantage dominating a niche
you know becoming a specialty business
this is the h-e-b markets in Texas
h-e-b is a regional chain of grocery
stores in Texas that have competed
successfully against Walmart down there
and the way that they've done so is
they've been really attentive to micro
Nisha's of their client base Latinos for
example they sell ingredients and
cooking equipment that is very much in
demand in the Latino community
Asian Americans they have aquariums of
fish for people to get live fish you
know for for cooking they have they've
been focusing on very poor customers -
and figuring out what are the foodstuffs
that would be particularly useful to
people on an extremely limited income
and you know through these kinds of
micro niches local businesses do quite
well because if you think about you know
chain stores almost by definition have
to generalize at some mega level direct
distribution how do you compete against
the mega mall that supposedly puts
convenience in the hands of customers in
one place well you make it even more
convenient for consumers to get
foodstuffs locally this guy runs spud
small potatoes
urban delivery system in Vancouver
British Columbia spud will deliver to
your doorstep 300 varieties of fresh
fruits and vegetables in biofuels
vehicles in short order now what I
really want is this guy to get involved
in diaper delivery a couple a couple
months ago my wife was traveling I have
two young kids and at about 10 o'clock
at night
on Saturday night I realized I was out
of diapers I would have paid this man
$100 to direct deliver me a single
diaper at ten o'clock on Saturday night
I know I can't be alone and my point is
is that if we cleverly start organizing
local businesses to work collaboratively
together they can set up direct delivery
systems Amazon says they'll get you a
book in 24 hours we need the local
bookstore to be able to get you the book
in 24 minutes riding the long tails some
of you may have seen an article by Chris
Anderson in Wired magazine 2-3 years ago
talking about one of the things that the
Internet has done is it means you know
people who used to have tiny audiences
and never could make a living at it now
can actually create huge audiences in
really tiny niches so what I mean by
that is you know if you were a garage
band in Pittsburgh you know and you used
to have an audience of maybe you know
seven people and there and there you
know Canaries now you can go all over
the world and find those seven people in
tens of thousands of cities and you have
got an audience out there so it means
that more people can do more things in
almost any community using global
technology cleverly now I want to
finally talk about emerging community
strategies because what I just talked
about us what local businesses on their
own for the most part can do to become
more competitive but the smartest thing
for a community to do is actually to
build a coalition of local businesses as
Bali has done around the country because
local businesses together are capable of
doing all of
things on this list and they may not be
capable of doing them if they're not
working together so I have it kind of in
six P's of planning people partners
purse purchasing and policymaking
planning I mean let's identify leaks in
the economy and plug them people how do
we support either new or existing
entrepreneurs partners how do we build
networks of local businesses that can be
more competitive working together purse
how do we deal with this problem of
equity investment getting into the hands
of local businesses purchasing how do we
encourage consumers businesses public
purchasing agents to buy local or buy
local first I'll say more about that in
a moment and policymaking
I have a very simple goal of public
policy stop destroying local business
just level the playing field if you just
did that that's all that local
businesses need and we could save a lot
of money too let me talk briefly about
each of these give you a sense of what
I'm talking about local planning the
starting place of any coherent
localization agenda is to identify all
of those things that the community is
unnecessarily buying from outside the
community that are leading to leakages
of dollars because if you can plug those
leaks to locally made goods locally
provided services you can get a whole
lot of additional local multiplier so
I've done about a half dozen studies and
initiatives around the country with
community groups and the
longest-standing one was in upstate New
York in Saint Lawrence County and this
commenced with the with st. Lawrence
University a couple of state
universities in New York and with the
Chamber of Commerce up in st. Lawrence
County st. Lawrence County is the
largest landmass county in upstate New
York
it's one of the poorest counties in the
state they have about a hundred thousand
people we organized several hundred
people in st. Lawrence County into teams
around different sectors of the economy
and the challenge we put to them was
please identify the leaks in your sector
and what are the best opportunities for
new or expanded local businesses to plug
those leaks to get people started I gave
folks some data around the economy
things they may not have known for
example land there was a quarter of a
million acres of vacant farmland because
of recent farms that had gone bankrupt
there were 3,700 people on or
underemployed in st. Lawrence County
which for New York State was a
relatively high percentage there's a
billion dollars in banks and credit
unions that in theory could be used as
investment in local businesses and I
estimated another five billion dollars
in pension and mutual funds so I sat
down with the food and agriculture group
I want to give you just one example of
how we have logic of this played out and
we were looking at meat leakages now I
know there's some vegans here so my
apologies but if you look at the meat
situation in st. Lawrence County they
import 15,000 cows worth of beef and and
they raise four thousand so they have so
you have a net importation of eleven
thousand cows this is Ana County that
brags that we are the top dairy county
in the United States they're importing
thirty six thousand pigs worth of bacon
more or less off reliant on lamb and
importing 2 million chickens the chicken
number was of special interest to me so
I said to the food
Rakolta group I said okay let's think
this through
we have in st. Lawrence County a quarter
of a million acres of abandoned farmland
we have 3700 people unemployed we have
six billion dollars of potentially
investable capital and you're importing
every year 2 million chickens does
anyone see a business opportunity here
well flash-forward five years no
chickens but they have set up an energy
service company that is plugging energy
leaks they have a farm to school program
that is plugging some of those dairy and
beef leaks
another thing that they're doing I I
love this picture this the woman here is
the head of the Chamber of Commerce
Karen st. Hilaire this is a giant
monster carp from a local lake that no
one will touch no one will eat and st.
Lawrence kind this is a Brit who loves
said carp idea let's invent a great
tradition of the park carp tournament
some thousands of Brits descend on st.
Lawrence County each year for the annual
carp tournament and this has been a
great driver in the economy now I want
to highlight here that this tourism
scheme did well because the local
restaurants and hotels are locally owned
if they were chain hotels and
restaurants this scheme would not have
worked entrepreneurship lots of things
going on with youth entrepreneurs
mentorship programs incubators
interesting point incubators are these
physical establishments to help nurture
local businesses or help nurture
businesses we should say there are a
thousand incubators in North America
that's the good news the bad news
is that nearly all of these incubators
are focused on high-tech nanotech
biotech what at the end of the day are
Tina wannabes so what happens is is that
the public pours all this money into
these incubators good companies come out
of them and then they go public and they
disappear and all your money was for
naught we've got to be much more
intelligent about how we focus
incubators on Louis and try to create
ownership structures around these
businesses that come through the
incubators local business alliances you
know we've talked already about Louis
shopping malls we're starting to see
ideas of how local businesses come
together to do things that they couldn't
do alone production-wise for example
wind farms it may be that one farmer
can't afford to put up a windmill but a
bunch of farmers could afford to put up
a small number of windmills and use that
to supplement their income producer
cooperatives are a very important piece
of the puzzle true value hardware stores
have competed effectively for home
against home depot but never have
sacrificed their local character that is
true value hardware stores are all
locally owned but they are members of a
national producer cooperative that just
like Home Depot goes out in the world
scours the universe for good deals buys
in bulk delivers the savings to their
members stores we need these kinds of
arrangements in a knot and a lot more
categories than hardware now you can do
this at a local level too
and an example of this is Tucson
originals Tucson originals is a group of
food producers in Tucson Arizona
restaurants and value-added
manufacturers of food who work together
buy food stuffs collectively buy kitchen
equipment collectively in bulk bring
down their costs that way
and thereby improve their
competitiveness strategy number four
think local first no place like home
that's why I have Dorothea up there now
I want to talk about this for a second
every time you're tempted to make an
expenditure at a chain store stop and
see if there's a comparable purchase
same quality and price that you can find
at a local business we're trying to get
people to be better shoppers that's
really the essence of this here are a
bunch of tools that are being used
around the country coupon books there's
probably 20 cities right now that have
these coupon books this is from
Bellingham Washington if you use all the
coupons in this where the locals go book
you save about sixty four hundred
dollars in your purchases this is the
best selling book in the local book
store this tool actually makes money and
most of these ideas that I'm giving to
you by the way if they're done properly
they require some investment upfront but
they should be money makers and you
there you know then can start building
other things off of them we're seeing
labels that are being done you know
either in a casual or systematic way
these foodstuffs are local this business
is locally owned this product was made
locally by local weeks by local Philly
by local San Francisco local gift cards
debit cards credit cards this is a local
debit card from Santa Fe New Mexico one
out of ten residents of Santa Fe now
carries this card since this card was
issued by the Los Alamos Savings Bank a
local bank that Bank has moved from
number four in Santa Fe to number one
because everyone is now moving their
deposits into the los alamos bank out of
global banks to be part of this every
time you use
local debit card at a local business you
get a discount that accumulates for
further expenditures at other local
businesses again this is a project that
they expect to generate significant
revenue streams down the road and these
streams will then be used to develop
other kinds of Business Alliance
activities local investing my my focus
in the last couple of years on how to
solve this problem with local investing
is to create local stock exchanges if
you think about it unless we help small
businesses create local stock you can't
create widespread community ownership in
the stock so local stock is kind of a
logical prerequisite for moving towards
local ownership of the economy well this
is a very interesting story here at the
mercantil in Powell Wyoming pow Wyoming
tiny town couldn't attract any chain
store to come in they had no place to
buy their socks and their underwear but
they decided you know what we're gonna
we're gonna build our own general store
they need money to do it they needed
about three quarters of a million
dollars so they created a small stock
issue they got volunteer legals helped
to create it it didn't cost them a
hundred thousand dollars and they sold
these stock shares door-to-door like
Girl Scout cookies they raised their
three quarters of a million dollars this
thing has been going profitably now for
five years there's a half dozen of these
mercs in the Rocky Mountain States right
now and they are great examples of how
creating local stock not only is a great
means of capitalizing business but also
a way of building customer loyalty
because the owners of course are going
to be coming to the store all the time
and the next stage in this is building
electronic stock exchanges so that we
can help people who own these shares buy
and sell them with one another on a
local basis and I've been making some
I've been doing some work with some
securities folks around the country on
creating this platform we can talk about
this afterwards anyone is interested
finally on local policymaking there's a
lot of things here that you know we
could talk about but I just want to talk
about a couple of things that I think
are sort of low hanging fruit on moving
things in the right direction what is a
tax credit a very small tax credit could
make an enormous disc difference for
creating local stock and I wanted to I
want to give you an example of this I
don't know the law all the kind of pork
things that Pennsylvania has for Tina
but in Maine we give investors a 40%
write-off a tax credit not write off the
tax credit on every dollar that they put
in qualified main businesses what is a
qualified main business if you are an
advanced Tina manufacturer building a
factory in Maine you qualify if you are
a branch of a tina bank you qualify if
you are a local business and you don't
qualify this is crazy crazy old economic
development logic obsolete disproven
what is a lot well but imagine just
tweaking this law ever so slightly and
we simply add one sentence in that says
you also get the 40 per 10% tax credit
when you invest in local business
suddenly all of the investment
institutions in the state would move
this way the hedge funds the mutual
funds the venture funds the pension
funds everyone would want a piece of
this action now we don't even need 40%
you know one or two person
of a tax credit for local investment at
a state level would make this kind of
difference procurement preferences can
you get Pittsburgh to buy goods and
services preferentially locally there
are ways of doing this that I believe
are consistent with trade law and also
consistent with good free market
economics by focusing on the multiplier
impacts of local bidders but you should
know that there are two dozens
communities out there including
Washington DC that give across-the-board
preferences to local businesses that
compete for municipal or state contracts
finally there's the incentives law now
look everything that I have shared with
you tonight
cost something it costs some money to do
leakage analysis to do entrepreneurship
programs to create business alliances to
create local stock markets it costs some
money to do local first campaigns at
least get them started but none of these
things cost very much money and it again
if we do them properly they should be
revenue generators many of them fifty
billion dollars a year is being spent at
the local and state level to attract or
retain on local business that is the
vast majority well over ninety percent
of what is being spent in the name of
economic development today my position
is we should simply end the practice
across the board and take that money
spend some of it on the things that I've
just talked about that are not being
done in economic development except for
a few things in entrepreneurship and
give the taxpayers a massive refund on
an annual basis with the other money and
I think one can build an interesting and
powerful left-right coalition around
these ideas where I want to leave you is
scene from indiana jones and the last
crusade you may recall that after
indiana had suffered through snakes and
spiders terrorists flying blades he
comes to a crypt with the holy grail and
there's a 500 year old guardian that
says indiana your last task will be to
choose from among these fifty goblets
choose from which goblet christ drank
and choose wisely well at that point
this guy the German spy says I know
which one Christ would have run from it
would have been the most ornate he
drinks from it and he spontaneously
combusts at that point The Guardian says
he chose poorly
well my argument is is that all of us
are choosing poorly right now we're
choosing poorly by not doing leakage
analysis as an essential part of our
economic development we're choosing
poorly as consumers by not buying local
first we're choosing poorly as investors
by not thinking about creative ways of
putting our pension funds into local
business we're choosing poorly as public
policymakers by not weeding out all of
these foolish expenditures on attraction
and retention that should be focused on
local businesses I think there's you
know in some ways this is a very
practical agenda but this is also a
revolutionary one and that's why I want
to quote Patrick Henry with one minor
edit from the Revolutionary War why
stand we hear idle is life so dear or
peace so sweet as to be purchased as
price of chains forbid it Almighty God I
know not what course others may take but
as for me give me community or give me
death thank you very much
thank you rumor has it we have some
microphones for questions I will make my
answers short if we could do relatively
short questions we'll just try to work
our way through whatever people want
answer so the grab one of the
microphones just because we're being
recorded for posterity and lawsuits
I grew up in Brooklyn alright
right so you're talking about is success
comes at a price usually and rising land
values will sometimes crowd out the
people who made that success possible
and I think you know one one approach to
this is you know how do you in a market
friendly way keep low income housing
successfully operating in the community
and I think one of the best examples
I've seen of this is the Burlington Land
Trust
so taking land trusts and you know we
tend to think of land trusts as
contiguous land but in Burlington and in
other places you know these are parcels
here and there and one puts them
together in a trust and you know you
give people hundred year leases and you
make sure that the price of housing
stays affordable for people over the
long haul that way I mean if we had done
more of this a lot of today's housing
crisis would not have taken place and I
think the author should use that kind of
technique not just for a residential
land but also for commercial land if one
wants to do sort of smart growth
development and buy all of these sort of
gap teeth and neighborhoods put them
together and then carefully make sure
that those lands are nurtured for smart
growth rather than the next you know
chain-store boondoggle you can move
economic development in much better
direction
when you were talking about purchasing
responsibly you are saying that if
you're talking about buying local first
and choosing a product that was that was
a local product in benign
if you could so with if there was the
local product available but when it
comes to when it comes to buying too
oftentimes the whole point is that there
are foods that are not in season so you
can't have strawberries whenever you
want them you can see this is where the
think local first gets interesting
because it really I mean I I was too
short and it describing it I mean at the
end of the day I think what think local
first is about is not just shopping
around for the best prices but shopping
around for the smartest way of meeting
your needs okay and so what you're
mentioning is look if we can start to
teach people that you know you can have
great meals using seasonally appropriate
local ingredients that is one way of
localizing and keeping down your food
costs there are some books out there
recipe books out there I've done work
with a group in New Jersey that called
eating fresh that has a bunch of these
recipe books out there and I think it's
a great strategy but think about it in
other areas too for example you know I
have a list in the small Mar book of you
know of my sort of platter of things
that I go through as I think local first
so my top item is not to buy if I can
find a way to borrow it reuse it recycle
it you know dumb down my fashions
ability you know whatever it takes
that's like the best way of saving money
and localizing health care okay we have
a generation of Surgeon General's from
both Republican and Democratic
administrations who all say exactly the
same thing the way to bring down health
care costs in this country is to focus
on prevention rather than treatment well
to the extent that you focus on
prevention you're focusing on local
stuff you're focusing on exercise good
nutrition all the food systems we're
talking about here we're focusing on you
know good family counseling and prenatal
care things that are very labor and
local service intensive it's only when
you get to later things like end-of-life
high-tech equipment or high-tech
pharmaceuticals which are at the
treatment phase pretty much that you
know that you get non-local so doing the
right thing in healthcare will bring
down costs and necessarily localize
ourselves where energy is another great
example your Rocky Mountain Institute
says that the typical family even today
is leaving three thousand dollars a year
on the table in unnecessary expenditures
on electricity and fuels and these are
things that if we did the cost-effective
energy efficiency things we could save
money and localize that money as well so
there's a long list of things like this
that if we just approach the need
differently
we will save money and localize there
was a baby with a question
suck local fun first two more it
impressed me about the st. mark study I
was thinking maybe I should move up
there a little chicken farm I have a
question related to your comment and
aren't affordable in terms of local
purchasing all the ways they spoke about
little which I'm a big fan of and I can
also say a hidden secret of mine is I'm
tempted by dollar stores and sometimes I
go in there and however right now I'm
speaking about a class play that is an
ever-growing problem with the rich
getting richer and I don't need that
$30,000 being on the or in a lot of our
eyes but over the course of time it may
get a lot more and people are tempted by
those big boxes so how do you say that
affordable goes locally when I know that
when I go to buy locally with just a lot
of the time sometimes it's 30 percent
more you know in cost you know I guess
the first thing I would say is no one
should ever spend more money on local
goods or services if they don't want or
can't afford to and I I believe that
across the board so I have tried to
frame my arguments on ways that
consumers can genuinely save money and
so the examples you gay give it sounds
like you've been a careful shopper and
in some things you see that you're not
able to find appropriate or good local
goods or services and you should not be
buying local on those things but one of
the things that a local first movement
can do is it can compile information
about lots and lots of things that you
is
single shopper will never be able to see
on your own and we have to remind
ourselves that our template in our minds
about the great deals and box stores is
driven by tens of billions of dollars of
advertising so I you know it's
definitely had an impact on my thinking
as well but what what I what you realize
happens at the box stores is there's a
small number of loss leaders you know on
the corners as you walk in there are
significant discounts and then a lot of
the other things aren't actually not all
that different and sometimes they're
more expensive in Maine give you an
example every year the state does an
analysis of prescription drug prices and
it turns out that local pharmacies have
lower prescription drug prices than
Walmart or any of the box stores do the
reason is the local stores have a
producer cooperative that are buying
those drugs in bulk
now that is data that a good local first
campaign gets out to people and moves
your needs for people without lots of
money a lot closer so I mean I just
don't think we should approach local
first as an a pro information Pro market
study we are going to get as much
information as we can to people to help
them get by better understanding in your
research that really believes and knows
that local is affordable to you for
instance produce clothing I mean when I
buy the local okay I'm spending a lot a
lot more money when I'm buying local
produce now they're upping their prey
constantly because they know it's
desirable so you know what is your
research in that area right so the
research the thing is is that no
generalization will do justice to the
question you know we've got tens of
millions of products tens of millions of
services out there each are unique and
anyone you know whether it's me or you
know the mister big box out there anyone
who tries to generalize and say big is
cheaper local is cheaper do not believe
them there is no general answer to this
the only answer is they're smart
shopping and there's dumb shopping ok
and and what I have seen is that if
you're a smart shopper you can localize
ten twenty thirty percent of what you're
spending a chain stores now and save
money that's that's been my experience
and the experience of many of the
communities I work with not everything
but you know what's what's a part of
this is also remember again retail is a
small part of the economic picture and
we're letting retail dominate okay but
say you buy a cup of coffee who's gonna
argue with a straight face that
Starbucks has the cheaper cup of coffee
who's gonna argue with a straight face
that you know the high-end food at
Trader Joe's is the cheapest high-end
food you're going to find I mean I think
that that we have to we have to bring a
lot more detail and nuance to this whole
picture
even if we're focusing on retail
and using any communities where in this
bike rack by local unity know about
nationally but we have regularly to try
to get small farmers visible in there in
the retail marketplace if you see in any
communities across the country where
there have been really good efforts to
communicate I mean I think if you look
at some of the best bali networks out
there I mean you know Bellingham
Washington is a great one so one of the
things you might do is is Bellingham
every year & Belling it by the way is a
community of 90,000 people about an
hour-and-a-half drive north of Seattle
on the coast and you know they have just
been working at this for years now and
they have seven full-time people working
on local economy stuff one of them does
food stuff things full-time and does you
know campaigns throughout the community
and every year they do a film or a DVD
kind of showing highlights of activities
and food is a very big piece of that and
I think you would get some interesting
flavor of what these public campaigns
look like from those DVDs you know in in
Philadelphia you're gonna you're gonna
hopefully come back and listen to Judy
wicks who is you know one of the great
pioneers of these ideas in Philadelphia
and you know she has built networks of
local restaurants that are increasingly
advertising marketing purchasing
together and I think you know it is
transformed the food picture of
Philadelphia
your cat for those of you who don't know
his hat buy fresh buy local comes from a
national organization with I think they
now have maybe 50 to 100 networks around
the country called food routes and these
networks are all coming up with creative
marketing stuff so it's I mean we are in
a sea of great local food ideas these
days in some ways food has been the easy
one because people sort of get it
intuitively instinctively you know they
they sort of can taste the difference
and feel the trust of the health of the
local farmer but it's harder in areas
like banking or stock or energy and you
see any change happening with a movement
or local will there be changes in the
nonprofit sector for instance many
nonprofits are funded by large
corporations some low I mean here in
this program Pines and do a lot of local
initiatives you see what kind of changes
do you see in them we have to spend at
least a few days on that one so let me
begin by just identifying a piece of the
nonprofit world that people may not be
aware of which is that the typical
American family spends $1300 on charity
a year many people foolishly don't spend
that money on local charity and simply
localizing those dollars can have an
enormous economic impact so there is an
exam another example of where
localization costs you nothing but it
gets you some real important dividends
beyond just the
charity itself changes in the nonprofit
sector I think you know there's a lot of
talk now that wasn't there 20 years ago
about nonprofits be more entrepreneurial
but sadly I think most foundations don't
really support it that is they talk
about you know self-reliance and
becoming you know solve funded but they
really mean by that is you're not
getting a grant from us you're getting a
grant from them and we're gonna
diversify your sources of grant support
that to me is a dead end and I I you
know I worked in that field for years
and years and finally concluded that you
know nonprofits have some interesting
functions to serve in the world but
actually for profits are where social
change is really at right now and and I
think I mean it's a perversity of
American life that we believe somewhere
in the back of our minds that for
profits are suspicious and nonprofits
are do gooders when in fact the
nonprofit's are boards of people who
elect themselves year after year and
have no accountability whereas at least
there is the possibility in corporations
of creating I mean it's not very good if
it's not local but if you have local
firms with local stakeholders you can
create some accountability there and
think about this if you're really
interested in political change in
lobbying and in pushing politicians you
can't spend any money as a nonprofit but
you can as a for-profit so you know I
mean I'm just pointing out the obvious
here I think that for-profit has a lot
of unexploited potential for social
change and justice for me there was kind
of a critical moment where my thinking
changed on all this when I I went I was
teaching in Japan and on the way I I
spent a few days with my family and
and we went to this restaurant
called cabbages and condoms has anyone
here heard of cabbages and condoms okay
three people three people who are
worldly out there cabbages and condoms
is it's a very large excellent and
affordable Thai restaurant every table
has a glass covering with growth of
multicolored condoms underneath there
are you know blow-up balloon like
animals made out of condoms on the walls
there are slogans you know our food
won't get you pregnant at the end of the
meal you get condom mints and it's
really in your face okay but this
restaurant along with I think it's about
15 or so other restaurants hotels and
resorts that are part of this change
chain den donates something like I don't
know ten or twenty million dollars a
year to reproductive rights and age AIDS
education in Thailand it's the biggest
movement for trying to curb the AIDS
epidemic in Thailand and as I thought
about this I thought you know if this
particular restaurant were operating in
the United States first of all if it was
foundation funded the foundations would
say you think you could tone it down a
little bit you're a little too much in
people's face or they would say you know
look why don't you do an education
campaign you shouldn't be focused so
much on the revenue generation side and
the whole thing would have been lost I
think working on the one thing all my
life that if you can develop you know
something that is mission related and
revenue generating it is it is the home
run out there and that's why in many of
the kinds of do economic development
programs I mean I think one of the
one of the silliest things about
economic development right now is that
we give anything to any business local
or non-local bite and demand nothing in
return
I mean at a minimum if you're gonna give
you know a million bucks to someone to
come in from out of town why not take
any equity stake and the company equal
to that and begin to build some equity
that allows you to do other things
instead we just give this money away
pointlessly and I think we should you
know we should really start thinking
entrepreneurially about economic
development yeah there's a lot of things
out there on industry standards the one
that I have gotten enthusiastic about
but you know it's still early in the
game it's called B corporation which
should be of special interest to people
in this room since it's the Pennsylvania
based company but what the beet
corporation people have done is they you
know there are many many different
standards out there for Social
Responsibility and they have to created
a really nice survey that a company can
do within one or two hours time and
really judge their performance based on
these questions on Labor Standards
environmental standards charitable
standards governance corporate
governance and then community and by the
way you can't score a perfectly on the B
Corp index unless you're locally owned
so they put local ownership in there as
one of the things but I
I like what they've done because it's
it's the reasonable compromise between
spending millions each year to do kind
of your own inventory which you never
can afford to keep up and doing nothing
and really giving companies some
sensibility of how they're performing
and steadily improving it there's a
underlying business model of the Corp
that you know remains to be tested so
we'll see but it's being you know
prototype now around the country I think
there's something like 500 companies
that are that are part of the B Corp
Network and there are similar things you
know internationally that are developing
as well let me add one other point about
this - which is that at the end of the
day there's only so much you can do with
certification you know we still need we
still need labor and environmental laws
and so while I hate to put you know too
much burden on the legal side of the
house being a lawyer I hate lawyers but
I do think that you know for things like
a living wage I think living living wage
laws make some sense and I know small
businesses really to test them but
raising Labor Standards through a floor
on wages is not a bad way of addressing
some working poverty out there and and
on you know in Santa Fe New Mexico they
did an across-the-board living wage they
thought it would wreck business in fact
the economy has thrived after living
wages because one thing people forgot
about living wage its Walmart repellent
chain stores whose model is to pay well
below the living wage will not set up
anymore in that community so it has some
unintended consequences
but I am 100% supportive of non local
businesses that try to honestly not
through local wash but honestly try to
engage in more localization so if we if
there are any chain store proprietors or
employers or supporters in in the in the
audience and you're thinking well are
there pieces of this we can adapt of
course there are of course are in fact
you know most of the things that I
talked about in terms of local supplies
and supporting local entrepreneurs and
working with local entrepreneurs to bid
on larger contracts and bidding on
public contracts along with local
businesses I mean there's all kinds of
things that Louis and Tina can and
should be doing in partnership and we
should support that but we should not be
supporting it with public money okay and
that's where I draw the distinction I
welcome and embrace all businesses but I
do not embrace public policy that is
focusing the dollars on the wrong thing
I think Tina will do fine without public
money I think over time because of the
trends that I mentioned Tina businesses
are going to lose some ground and in
some cases they're gonna lose ground
dramatically but there are some products
and some businesses out there that large
economies of scale still exist and will
exist for a very long time and you know
they will coexist side by side by Louis
what I mean to put this in some kind of
numerical context I I think you know
we're probably we're probably going to
see
move from 58% local local businesses I
think over the next 10 or 20 years to 70
or 80 percent the remainder will be Tina
and actually and ironically the volume
of trade among many of these players
could well go up because localization is
a wealth building strategy as I get
wealthier as a self-reliant community
and an individual I will spend some of
my wealth on non local consumption so
let me be let me give you an example
that I have moved my mortgage in the
last two years from Bank of America to a
local credit union I save several
thousand dollars as a result of doing
that with my savings I spend some
portion of that I won't tell you how
much on single malt whiskey coming from
Scotland so I have funneled some of that
into greater trade but it's not a very
heavy good and you know high value-added
at the same time I have money that I can
invest in all kinds of local businesses
some which are focused on local markets
some of which are focused on global
markets so if every community can add to
its wealth through localization we will
see more robust global trade which
raises then the environmental issue that
to get to the kind of world we're
looking for we have to start thinking
about other ways of waiting trade
against things with high carbon
footprints and toward things with low
carbon footprints so we should not be
treated you know trading in heavy stone
from China for construction that's a
nutty thing to trade it we might you
know microcircuits okay that I can
understand to do that we need green
taxes we need to move our tax system to
carving taxes I see that as inevitable
if we can start doing that at the local
would be a great a great step in the
right direction so I've strung together
a lot of different things here to answer
your question but the bottom line that I
want to give and maybe we'll conclude on
this note is that localization has been
Burlesk t' for a generation as people
spending more on things that they don't
really need and in fact the smarter way
of doing localization is to be a better
shopper a better investor a better
planner and spend on those things that
are going to generate more wealth
locally and if you do that right and
combine it with the other public
policies week have it shot it's not a
guarantee but a shot of moving our
economies and moving our sustainability
in the right direction thank you again
for coming this evening
you